all I got is this and some water and it
came up to 177 dollars that's crazy I am
Maybe
because of the price of meat can no
longer afford it Gas City going up going
up but uh uh people paycheck ain't going
up until they actually realize what's
going on out here we're going to
continue suffering like this about 300
million feeling the same way let's bring
in our panel right now syndicated radio
hosts Hugh Hewitt's with us tonight
Morgan Ortega's former State Department
spokesperson back with us tonight and
Josh crash hour axio senior political
correspondent Josh good evening to you
as well Hugh kick it off what are we and
what is this president in for in the
months and potentially years to come
well anyone who's under the age of 62
which includes everybody but me on this
panel Bill do not remember what this is
like when I got out of college in 1978
inflation was 7.6 1979 it went to
11.3 and in 1980 it went to 13.5 if
you're young and just going into the
workforce or you're old and on a fixed
income inflation destroys your ability
to make a living and what it also does
is destroy a president and a party and
the Democrats are going to get wiped out
it takes a Reagan it takes a republican
Congress to cut spending cut taxes in
the states and the federal level because
right now people are going through
something they've never gone through
before folks on Social Security Got A
5.6 percent Cola that's already gone and
the military pay raise and the budget
this year 4.6 percent we already heard
9.1 percent year over year it's a
disaster for the country that's tough uh
one man who was there in the cockpit was
Art Laffer in the early 80s he saw it
firsthand a bit earlier today he had
this forecast
we will continue to see these numbers go
up and up and up there it's accelerating
and this thing is out of control this is
about as bad as it gets and combined
with the employment numbers which are
not good for this Administration I don't
see how they pull out of a crash Morgan
do you have an answer for that
I did I mean listen this this feels very
much like 2008 the financial crisis and
there were so many young people at that
time whose careers really stopped we're
still seeing the effects of the
financial crisis in terms of Millennials
not buying homes still having student
debt and I think this economy may be on
track to have that that type of
ramification for older people who can't
retire for younger people who aren't
going to be able to save and leave home
and buy their own home and listen I
think the administration the Biden
Administration is experiencing something
that people don't like to experience in
Washington and that's when the reality
of your policies come to fruition and
they've failed well it's hard to admit
that they're not working right it's hard
to admit that maybe it was a stake
mistake spending to a trillion dollars
and look no further by the way where
they're going to hurt the most in
November will be with minority
communities you have 29 percent of
Hispanic Americans approving of Biden's
job performance 49 percent of black
Americans give Biden a positive approval
job rating these are devastating numbers
for any Democrat uh president and
they're not going to get better anytime
soon because they've refused to admit
reality yeah Josh a bit earlier today
Senator Joe manchin he put out a
statement quickly part of it read like
this no matter what spending aspirations
some in Congress may have it is clear to
anyone who visits a grocery store or gas
station that we cannot add any more fuel
to this inflation fire can you gauge the
impact on an election 118 days from now
yeah well don't expect Joe manchant to
support any new spending as much as
Democrats may want him to but this is
Hugh hit the nail on the head that we
haven't seen this degree of inflation
since the Jimmy Carter Administration
and we know how that ended up in the in
the 70s and look this is a political
political headwind for the for this
Administration I'm a little perplexed
too Bill that this Administration hasn't
really acknowledged the degree of
inflation they were spinning today that
gas prices are going down a little bit
and the report didn't reflect that that
Dynamic but every other good good food
Gas Energy you name it the the core
inflation rate was was through the roof
and when you can't acknowledge reality
when you have trouble uh acknowledging
the the challenge in the first place
it's hard to to spin it in a positive
direction and have a plan to solve the
problem you're probably right about that
I've got two minutes Around the Horn
quickly Hugh what is to be expected from
this trip in the Middle East
president is trying to reassure allies
who a year after the Afghanistan debacle
do not trust the American promises being
made he's going to have to double down
and triple down on those promises
because those memories of people falling
from planes are still fresh wow wow what
a moment Morgan uh this was your
department yeah this is what comes from
it yeah
uh the bite Administration has
squandered the past 17 months as it
relates to the Middle East they were
handed the Abraham Accords they rejected
every single policy that we put in place
that led to the four peace deals the
first in 26 years
um and they have failed they got played
by the by the Iranians they have
absolutely no intention of going into
the jcpoa everybody knows that I don't
think they can fix it on this trip but
hopefully they can start to course
correct Josh goal number one worked with
the Saudis and the Israelis to contain
Iran the jcpoa is dead there's not going
to be another Iran nuclear deal so
they're going to have to work with with
their allies in the region to help help
constrain Iran's nuclear Ambitions and
number two just get getting the oil
supply from the Saudis back back in our
favor and start to work diplomatically
with them again it's kind of striking
they're working with Russia and I think
the United States would like them to be
back in our Corner even though it's a
very delicate dance with that Saudi oil
thing is no guarantee even on this trip
Josh right no guarantee and the Saudis
have been moving away from the American
orbit given given the challenges we've
had since the khashoggi situation we
will pick it again tomorrow as that trip
continues nice to see the three of you
thank you Morgan Josh and Hugh Hewitt
thanks hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
that I
that news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now